look at this tired gross half human half
koala I'm talking about me hi Tim has
not seen the Lamar Me's uh Danis on on
fire lamb name by the way
oh come on give him half a chance I
don't actually know so I want to film
Tim reacting to dance video right no
actually I was ok shut up we're gonna
watch it I didn't mean to say shut up
I spent the save stop too late you're
ready to party ali-a octet ah we are
interrupting the normal dead
broadcasting schedule I don't know no
this isn't a Thursday what's happening
is something wrong
so don't worry cuz I have something very
exciting to announce ok oh my god that
guy is charming does it to be a team
captain we're super no 2012 whoa there
is good she can be I know God with us
the labor connects then I'll slap it as
far as a chef Lee buckle oh here's him
dead is he really a nice over they are
yeah you can't see captain these teams
are going to be back all the time if you
do this super champion of 2012 I'm sorry
can carriers and the ironwork the way
this works is I will attempt to make the
longest note that I can and then you
guys if you want to join my team I do no
stop oh no I will post a video response
unlike video no side edit long enough
that you can call it no police car do
you have a youtube account you can't be
part of team Dan London then the length
of all of our teams nodes will be added
together to determine a final score and
the winner will be in our newsletter
names is this part of you amazing not
yet somewhere so to be honest I feel
like this is meant to be this is a
pretty big deal on YouTube guys serious
business but the thing is I am against
some pretty big established youtubers in
this but I know how often you guys are
you guys don't just watch videos you
post video responses you believe me in
the comments you photoshop my
giraffes everybody who watches this
really takes part I actually think that
we could win this
it's got sincere and that would be the
first time I've ever won seven it's just
so much that because it's all about fun
there's no money involved it's just
about community and fun yo I own glory
but other than Brunei just on a person
like you hold longest no will win an
official down llama a giant shout out in
one of my videos and a personalized card
that I will make for us into your a car
I want that hat it's a bit creepy but I
hope that you'll like it but other
people that enter will win some cool
stuff like total rows and wristbands
so again you've got Totoro what are they
you just have to post a video response
to this video by going down to the
comment box and clicking post a video
that's video seconds it's mine for two
minutes if you're really awesome okay
it's time for my attempt are you gonna
watch a free girl yeah well anybody's
guess Phil's there not only for the win
yeah look at this he's wearing the head
one I can be cute you trying to
I know
rubbish as it could have been whoo no my
high-fives gonna my gosh the only mine
house did mine with the longest yes I
will try again unless amazingphil yes
that's the spirit bill yes so you make a
video doing it just like that
yes but no girl from the grudge
impression that doesn't count
No so if you want to take part you want
to know what this is all about I will
put a link down to Breton links video
explaining it in the description as
you're listening to their website which
has all the rules and the rankings on it
that's right guys this is official stuff
right now it's going down but yes the
shirts on I am generally excited I have
something to prove we are the underdogs
of the Internet if we want the line I
know now that a nice genuine display the
undercut or help and that means you
don't have second read anyone be like a
Camilla I post a video response and then
get your friend who doesn't like YouTube
as fast an account to do one then make
an account for your mum so she can be or
than your dad and your dad on music that
sounds to try to get as many people as
you can to do it because this is when we
prove anything that despite all of our
terrific social awkwardness is we can't
be champions of the Internet
let's do this I'll be looking through
all the video responses that I get in
commenting on them so I look forward to
seeing your super notes see you on
Thursday good bye
there's so many things about this Oh
give away your koala costume no I can't
I'll give away something else okay I see
you don't really want to win the team
what did you think overall
uh l'homme armé of Danis what is his
name
it is Matt on fire fire he's adorable
oh yeah yeah can you imagine you watch
the video
yeah I'm sorry I can't even talk right
now
all right and we'd been here by Daily
Grace and we're kinda cute